all right well i'd like to thank the
organizers for giving me this
opportunity to speak to you i'm going to
be talking about uh plant virus disease
mesa necrosis and its emergence globally
and you'll also learn a little bit about
mixed infections of viruses because this
disease is caused by a mixed infection
the first thing i'd like to impress on
you is that viruses are everywhere
we're all painfully aware now that
humans have viruses
but also we know animals have viruses
insects are among the animals that have
viruses plants also have viruses and
fungi have viruses bacteria have viruses
and archaea have viruses
and this impacts not only human health
but also plant health including the
plants that we produce for consumption
and for other purposes
and all of these different organisms in
the biota interact to
affect plant health
the american phytopathological society
have
encapsulated this concept with their
definition of the phytobiome
which they say just consists of plants
their environment and associated
communities of organisms so i'm showing
you an image here that shows plants and
all this associated
biotic and abiotic factors that impinge
upon their health and viruses impinge
upon
all of these different factors all the
different biotic factors in the system
and are important to consider in all of
the ways that they impact us as well
to next
um so some of the learning objectives
that i have for this talk are
to help you become aware of plant
infecting viruses if you weren't already
to identify ways that plant viruses can
be introduced to new locations
and describe some of the different ways
that plant virus diseases are managed
and possible outcomes of plant virus
mixed infections
i don't know the original origin of this
uh quote but on cdc you can see this
quote now that a disease threat anywhere
is a disease threat everywhere so when
something shows up in one place we're
such a global community now with people
and plants and
transit to different locations so
frequent
that the rate at which diseases and the
pathogens that cause them can move has
really accelerated in our current times
this review from 2004
talks about different ways that plant
viruses can emerge
plant diseases and other
caused by viruses and other pathogens so
you can see on the left hand is that
viruses account for a lot of emerging
diseases
in this study
of course fungi and bacteria
phytoplasmas nematodes and unknown
ideological agents can also be
responsible for plant diseases
and some of the big factors contributing
to the emergence are introduction as you
can see on the pie chart on the right
changes in vector population which are
pretty frequent now we're seeing vectors
or
changes in the genetics of vectors that
are in different locations now
um of course recombination and evolution
of pathogens and also weather and
farming systems can impact
the emergence of diseases or cause the
emergence of diseases often we don't
know exactly what has resulted in the
emergence of the disease
but all of these factors are really
important to consider
so i'm going to introduce a concept that
is really basic to plant pathologists
which is the plant disease pyramid which
i'm expanding out here to call the
plant disease triangle which i'm
expanding to a pyramid here with the
addition of a fourth component
so plant pathologists have known for a
long time that a pathogen in the cases
i'm talking about viruses
interact with their plant hosts and with
the environment so that when all of the
factors converge in a manner that is
conducive for disease
when we see the disease
and most plant viruses are transmitted
by arthropod vectors so plants don't
sneeze on each other and shake hands
but
they have mobile arthropods often that
are moving them from plant to plant and
producing their spread
and these arthropod vectors also have
interactions with plant hosts that they
feed on environmental factors that
influence their distribution and their
populations and so forth
so usually to manage plant viruses we
try to disrupt some part of the pyramid
here even a pyramid view is a little bit
simplified because
actually all of the different biota are
interacting with abiotic factors and
probably with viruses in a system and so
it could even be more complex than this
but for simplicity we'll look at the
pyramid here
so how do we prevent and manage
pathogen invasion and disease
well for viruses we're usually looking
to disrupt some
component or interaction of this disease
pyramid
so for viruses for example
on the top we might be working on
detection and diagnosis so that we can
prevent movement of pathogens to new
locations
and make sure that plants they were
putting in the field are clean
so clean plant programs exist for a lot
of
high investment plants like vines and
trees for example
and destroy reservoirs of the virus so
there's not a high amount of inoculum
for
the vector
you might have management strategies
like planting time so that you plant to
avoid the highest populations of an
important vector of the pathogen
insecticide treatments are sometimes
effective and sometimes not
preventing movement of the insects or
the arthropods are also important
and in some cases we have
ways to detect and predict populations
and then of course the environment is
important we we can't always change
what's going on on the outside but crop
management is manageable we can
implement crop rotations to reduce
reservoirs for vectors and viruses
manage weeds and other reservoirs for
either
and
good cultivation practices and even
location can all be important
for
disrupting conditions conducive for
disease
often with plant viruses the most
effective way to manage disease is to
have resistant plants to begin with
so
plants are selected for genetic
resistance and resistant varieties are
planted where possible
sometimes
natural genetic resistance is not found
and resistance can be engineered
like with papaya ring spot virus for
example
and crop rotation can also be really
important with the practices
in terms of having a plan
or implants susceptible to the diseases
that are
present or prevalent
and
what i'd like to point out there is that
most of these strategies rely on
prevention once you have infection
there's not a lot you can do
so here are a few viruses of maize
you might be wondering if you haven't
really looked for plant infecting
viruses before or
um hadn't really thought about them
before what
a diseased plant looks like when it's
infected by a virus
well there are far more examples than i
could possibly show you but here are a
few examples from uh some of my favorite
viruses that i've worked on over the
past several years
all infecting maize or corn as we call
it in the united states
so on the left on the far right you can
see maize chlorotic model virus which
creates
a symptom that plant virologists call a
mosaic so there's the light and dark
blotching or window painting in these
leaves
and that virus has an icosahedral virion
you can see on the bottom
the virus next to it on the right is the
storef mosaic virus also causes mosaic
that has a completely different
virus expression strategy and virus
particle
maize necrotic streak virus this mnesv
has a very bright streaking mosaic
that's a virus that would be hard to
miss
and my maze finds streak again has a
very strong mosaic
mrdv may's rough dwarf virus has
some interesting symptoms for a virus
these plants have shortened internodes
so they're squat they're shorter the the
distance between
the leaf nodes is reduced
and the leaves actually become a darker
green so instead of showing more
yellowing like the other ones that you
see on this page
they're actually a darker green
and i don't have an image of it here but
this virus also causes tiny little plant
tumors on the veins underneath little
nods little nodules
or enations as they're called
and mcbvv on
the the left
is a mesoclaronic dwarf virus which true
to its name causes dwarfing
and is found just in the veins
and so these veins are yellow where the
virus is so these are just a few of the
symptoms that might be caused by a virus
and if you start looking for plant
viruses they're everywhere
so now i'm going to move into
describing to you the emergence of mesa
lethal necrosis or mln
there was a major disease outbreak um
first described in kenya in fall 2011
and spring 2012
and it was such a problem that it
started showing up in in the popular
news which is kind of unusual for a
plant virus
but this disease
showed mosaic symptoms also necrosis or
tissue death and plant death
and it was associated with maize thrips
and this is really important in east
africa
where
maize is grown
as a human consumption staple crop
unlike in the united states where we use
it mostly for animal feed and industrial
purposes so here on the bottom right you
can see ugali which is from the white
corn
which is where a large portion of the
calories in east africa come from and
maize has grown there with multiple
crops
multiple maze crops in a year and
different stages might be in the field
at the same time
so on the left again you can see a plant
that is infected
and has measles across his symptoms
where you can see the the
necrosis on the margins of the leaf and
also
mosaic in the plant
so what was in the sick plants in kenya
well maize podi viruses were in there
and so i'll tell you a little bit about
what maze pony viruses are
these are viruses that have a
polyprotein expression strategy so they
produce one large polyprotein that is
proteolytically cleaved into a number of
different
mature virus proteins
it's a single-stranded positive sense
rna as many plant viruses are with
flexus rod virions
viruses
pony viruses are viruses that are
classified in the family podivir day of
plant viruses and they're really
ubiquitous just about every crop has
one or more pony viruses that infect it
and the maize infecting potato viruses
are in two different genera the genus
ponyvirus and the genus treatable virus
the ones in the genus podivirus are
aphid transmitted and wheat streak
mosaic virus which is the one in the
genus tritomovirus is transmitted by
wheat coral mites they all cause mosaic
symptoms and have these flexus rod
virions
and we weren't really surprised to see
those in east africa because podiviruses
have global distribution and have for as
long as we have looked for viruses and
corn
so
here i'm just showing you some of the
different
pony virus
species that are in corn throughout the
globe and what you can see is mdmv or
mainstore mosaic virus and an scmv
sugarcane mosaic virus on the top of
this chart
of worldwide distribution they were
known to be endemic in africa already
and there are a few others that have
been reported in different parts of the
globe
and wheat street mosaic virus which
treated its name is most impactful
actually in wheat as its host
but also infects susceptible corn
um
that is found in some places in the
globe as well so we weren't surprised to
find this in east africa sugarcane
mosaic viruses
very prevalent
but what was also in these samples is
this other virus mesoclerotic model
virus mcmv
and this virus has a completely
different expression strategy it's also
a positive sense rna virus it has
icosahedral virions
and it's unrelated to
the podiviruses that i just described
and this had been described in the
united states
it's readily mechanically transmissible
so humans can move it in the lab if
we're trying
and
in the continental united states its
vector was described as price of myelin
beetles
but it was also described in hawaii
where researchers found
that these thrips were transmitting it
and what's significant about these two
different viruses
is that we've known for a long time that
when you add have a mixed infection of
masochloratic model virus and any of a
number of these maze infecting pony
viruses you get maple lethal necrosis
and this is a synergistic reaction so
i'll take a moment to give you a
definition of synergism which is that
it's a much more exacerbated disease
than either single infection
in a quantitative terminology that would
be a more than additive disease output
but since there's not consensus on what
is being added i'll focus on the
qualitative definition here
so this was disease was originally
described called corn lethal necrosis in
the u.s by chuck niblet and colleagues
in 1978 what you can see in this image
from that publication on the left hand
side you see a single infection with
mcmv
followed by a single infection with
the podivirus mdmv and the treated
multivirus wheat streak mosaic virus any
one of which causes disease you can see
it's much more
uh severe when you have the combination
so on the left are two pots with mcmv
and mdmv in one and the far sorry the
far right is mcmv plus wheat street
mosaic and these plants are dead
these plants are dead
so that's what i mean by synergism
and you can see this plant from east
africa as well where you can see the
mosaic and the the death the necrosis
that's characteristic of maize lethal
necrosis
and mcmv is interesting because it has
emerged over time and quite rapidly in
the last 10 years
so a virus meeting the description of
mcmv was originally described in peru
if you look on the timeline on the
bottom here and then in kansas and
nebraska where chuck niblet described
corn lethal necrosis for the first time
and at later points it was
then described in argentina and thailand
followed by mexico and hawaii where
researchers found that thrips could
transmit mcmv
and then
shortly after 2010 there was an
explosion of mln
showing up about simultaneously in china
and kenya and other east african
countries and then in ecuador and spain
and still being reported in more places
so what led to the emergence of mln
well the short answer like most disease
emergencies is unfortunately that we
don't exactly know
we do have some clues in retrospect
so some of the important factors are
introduction of mcmv
for example in east africa researchers
had described corn infecting viruses and
had not found mcmv in previous decades
so it was almost certainly introduced to
these locations
since
ecuador as if it was in peru as early as
it was reported seems unlikely that
introduction um was new in the last
decade
whether it the vector was also
introduced or an efficient vector is
really unknown we just don't know a
whole lot about the maze thrips and its
distribution before and after
emergence
cultivation intensity is also a factor
um this is anecdotally believed in
ecuador to be important and the
emergence there um corn production was
was really intensified um just prior to
mln emergency or sorry emergence
and um finally the genotypes of corn
planted in these locations were
susceptible to both of the viruses both
the podiviruses and mcmv
unfortunately developing good resistance
to mcmv is still a work in progress by a
number of different groups
i just want to show you a few pictures i
took in tanzania so here's a an mln hot
spot in arusha where you can see a lot
of yellowing and death of these mature
plants in the field
and
you can see mosaic and also the necrosis
and all those little black spots on the
right are aphids so there are plenty of
vectors for
the pony viruses for sure
and here you can see tassels that are
weighed down with these aphids so plenty
of
vector load and plenty of virus load in
this field
and then on the over other side of these
bushes or trees here on
the right
there are young plants a new crop a
later planting showing up so these are
perfect new places for these insects to
go and transmit
more viruses and and deliver more and i
found thrips in these little yellowing
plants that you can see
and
fire symptoms starting to show up
already
this is from a survey in rwanda i just
want to show you how high the
load of virus sequences are this from
deep sequencing study
and
in some of these plants the sequences
matching
virus were even higher than the
sequences matching the plant that was
hosting them so mcmv highlighted in red
you can see really high
read counts
mapping to mcmv
compared to maze and these are selected
from polyadenylated rnas
looking at the sequences from various
surveys i don't have time to tell you
all about from kenya uganda rwanda and
tanzania
i and others found there's a lot of
variation in the scmv co-protein
at the n-terminus in particular and this
alignment just shows you that briefly
and
i in my lab also found that another hodi
virus also contributes to mln not
surprisingly this johnson grass mosaic
virus that we found in a number of
locations in these different countries
when we did mixed infections also caused
synergy just like we saw
with
mdmv and wheat street mosaic and
sugarcane mosaic so you can see the
single infected plants in this picture
and then the double infected plants that
are looking very dead
by comparison so absolutely synergistic
mln here
and why do those things matter well the
scmv co-protein is most often used as
the diagnostic to determine virus
presence in east africa
and the scmvs are very variable there's
a lot of diversity in
scmvs in east africa
and
probably the
isolate specific antisera are not
picking up all of them they don't pick
up jgmv
and so there's we i recommend using
broad spectrum diagnostics for
protoviruses to test these plants which
is important for limiting
movement to the virus and detecting what
disease is there
so what good does all this information
do
well i recommend the broad spectrum
diagnostics as i mentioned
because of the complex podi virus
populations that are there we don't have
time to show you all the trees and and
different sequences that i and others
have done
um but those are needed for the pony
viruses
mcmv is actually not very diverse
which is good news for detection
international movement containment is
also needed and one of the works in
progress is diagnostics for that an
assessment of seed transmission having
good regulation there and as i mentioned
earlier efforts to identify virus
resistance in maze are ongoing in a
number of different groups plant
resistance is really
often the most economical and most
practical way to manage disease versus
expensive
spray
strategies and good information are
needed to break disease propagation and
training people so they can recognize
when they have the disease so they know
what to treat for
and in the u.s we've had crop moratoria
be really effective in continental us
that's a little harder in places that
don't have winter
but crop and staple stapled
diversification and rotation it might
also be very helpful
now vector management is desirable but
um
cost effective methods to do this don't
really exist so there's a lot more work
needed still to manage this disease even
though it's been emerging now for a
decade
i want to talk a little bit at the end
here about
amaze infecting polarovirus that we also
found in studies
as another example of
an outcome of mixed infection
so this virus was found by my group and
others in samples across east africa and
then also in south america and asia so
it seems to be really prevalent globally
and
when we first found it it looked most
like this naseela door fire then
described
some years previously but it was
different enough that we knew this was a
different virus
and field incidences that were reported
in china and that we observed in
tanzania were very high this virus was
turning up in a large proportion of our
samples
and just showing you some of the
different places that we detected it
just
from from a few samples
so we um isolated this and
we're the first to isolate infect maize
alone with this virus and
remove it from other infected
viruses that were in samples because
this virus was often found in mixed
infections with
the viruses that we know cause mln in
the field
and identify
species of vectors and start to assess
disease
the name for this virus that's taken
hold in the literature is is
yellow mosaic virus that you can see
from our findings we it doesn't cause
yellowing it doesn't cause mosaic at all
it causes this kind of marginal
reddening which is more typical of what
we'd expect from a polarovirus we don't
know of any polaroviruses that cause
mosaic
and that's published work
but one of the questions we had
you know we know that mcmv plus a
poliovirus results in this disease mln
with defining features including mosaic
stunting and necrosis death
but because people weren't always
detecting a second virus with mcmv which
may have to do with diagnostics there's
been a wonder um
among people looking at this disease if
mcmv plus any stressor or any other
virus might result in mesolithium
necrosis
and since this polarovirus is quite
prevalent and often occurs in mixed
infections
we were wondering if
mei's chloratic model virus plus this
virus might result in measles necrosis
so we went about to test this
and have all these different
single infections treatments one two and
three
mock
which has all the inoculation treatments
and was the best control that we had and
then the double infections and the
triple infection that were possible
and we measured a bunch of different
parameters because we weren't quite sure
what things might be affected
by
these pairings these mixed infections
and we're looking for synergy and i told
you earlier there are multiple
definitions in the literature which is
true
so some of the definitions include more
than additive effects
but again what is added is not clear
different methods and different
researchers use different parameters
and not all of them are quantitative
increased multiplication of one or more
viruses is another definition of synergy
so in the case of mln
the titer of mcmv goes
way up it's already a high tide virus it
increases drastically and the podi virus
present
may increase decrease or stay the same
but you definitely have an increase in
titer of one of the viruses
in the case of mln
and another definition is exacerbation
of disease that may or may not be
accompanied by increased titer
so there's not a perfect universal
definition in the literature
unfortunately so this is another reason
we were looking at multiples
here
and what you can see is
the single infection plants um going
from the left
into double infections on the right and
treatment 7 is the triple infection and
treatment a is what we expect to be
mesolithomicrosis
and just from this image of 22 days post
inoculation you can see they look pretty
similar
but the treatments five and six look
maybe a little bit worse than the single
infections but not as bad as
as the treatments we expect to result in
these lethal necrosis
so we did scoring of reddening as one of
the parameters that we looked at because
we knew that the polarovirus caused
reddening
and what you can see is that sure enough
there's
reddening where the polarovirus is
present and here i'm showing you a
numerical version of this so the
treatments shown in red
have reddening and the ones that
don't have the polarovirus didn't have
redne
so reddening was only significantly
different from the mock when the polar
virus was present so we're pretty
confident that that particular symptom
was caused by that virus
and then we looked at mosaic and as i
told you mcmv and the podivirus scmp
both cause mosaic
and sure enough what we saw is that when
we had the polarovirus on its own we
never saw mosaic it looked just like the
the green bars which are mock and
healthy
and the red bar for um the polarovirus
is always the same at the different time
points
and this is just showing that in the
numerical format
where
again the polarovirus looks the same as
the healthy and mock
but there's a lot of mosaic when
the both of the viruses that rebuilt an
mln are present together
and it's significantly increased
compared to the single infections of
those mosaic-causing viruses
so again this mesomoza virus doesn't
cause mosaic in our hands and mosaic is
slightly enhanced in the triple
infection
and then we looked at this definitive
characteristic of necrosis which is
again defining for mesolethal necrosis
and we only saw it when mcmv was present
with fcmv so other pairwise combinations
of the polarovirus plus the podivirus or
the polarovirus plus mcmv never resulted
in necrosis
and then we looked at different measures
of stunting so the longest leaf length
was one of those and i will skip to the
longest leaf length chart here
and what you can see here is that
the stunting was most severe again in
the mln treatments
but there was certainly significant
stunting whenever the polarovirus was
present so this virus on its own and in
combination with other viruses
absolutely caused stunting
and another measure of stunting was to
look at the height of the highest collar
or node
and with that we had really similar
results so i'll skip over to the
chart here
and what you can see is again the
greatest stunting was observed in the
treatments where we expect an mln the
plus scmv
and then that treatment with also
polarovirus added in
and there was also
stunting in the double infections it was
significantly different
from single infections when the
polarovirus was in combination of the
others so it did seem to exacerbate
stunting
of
either of the other viruses in a
double infection
but not as much as when you had mlm
so finally i looked at virus titer
and this was very interesting in this
mixed infection
so i told you that when
in mlm the titer of mcmv is increased
so what you can see in this are the
tighter changes for the polarovirus in
red
the
mcmv in purple
and scmv in green
and what i'd like to point out to you
so if you look at the purple mcmv in the
middle
when it's all by itself in that second
row
um
the tighter is that's the single
infection tighter
and when you add the polaroid virus the
tighter is that
but not significantly different
but when you add sugar cane mosaic virus
in mlm treatment it's much higher so
that's
what we expect to see for that mixed
infection that's synergistic
interestingly in the triple infection
it was back down to where the single
infection level was even
perhaps the tighter increase isn't
essential for the synergistic disease
[Music]
and then the results for
the polarovirus in red
was really
the titer was comparable
when it was in a single infection
in a double infection with scmv
or in the triple infection
but it was reduced in the presence of
mcmv
and for scmv
it had its highest tider on its own
with slightly reduced titers in double
and triple infections
so this led me to
a model yes the palerovirus reduced
titers of each of the other viruses in
the mixed infection
scmv enhanced the titers of any virus
that it was with and mcmv slightly
reduced the other the titers of other
viruses and impaired infections
so the mixed outcome uh the mixed
infection outcome is a little bit
complicated here
so the polarovirus seems to inhibit the
tighter increase the scmv causes you can
see scmv on the top with these green
arrows showing it really enhances scmv
it also enhances the polaroid virus so
scmv seems to be
a good deal for any other virus that
it's with it seems to be increasing the
tighter of those viruses
mcmv has a more or less neutral effect
on
scmv it does reduce its titer somewhat
so sorry mcmv reduces the titer of both
spmv and maymv
not quite as much
and
maymv also reduces the tiger so the
mixed infection of
mcmv seems to be antagonistic towards
either of the other viruses polarovirus
also seems to be antagonistic where scmv
seems to help both
so the question is
does mcmv plus a polarovirus result in
mln
my answer is no mln is not recapitulated
in mixed infections that lack either
necrosis being a key symptom indicator
of mlm
but there are some inter interesting
interactions that are taking place so
the palerovirus does cause disease on
its own and does contribute to disease
including the reddening and very
significant stunting
which is not unexpected for a virus in
this group
and it does interact with other viruses
and mixed infections even though it's
not synergistic
with that
sort of mild negative effect as it seems
to have
and um
the stunting that this pathogen induced
suggests that it might actually be very
important the polarovirus often flies
under the radar because that little
reddening and and stunting that it
causes could easily be mistaken for
nutrient deficiency or poor growing
conditions it doesn't have the the i'm a
virus waving red flag like some of the
strong mosaics and other more obvious
symptoms
and we don't even always see the red
flag of the reddening of it
because sometimes plants are infected
and don't show that symptom
um so that those data are published at
this doi that i have listed here but it
shows us that there are some very
interesting
possible mixed infections and different
routes to disease from plant viruses
the learning objectives that i
placed out at the beginning
so i told you that i wanted you to
become aware of plant infecting viruses
and some of the different symptoms
and
problems that they can cause so
hopefully you've
collected that as you've listened to
this talk
that you can identify some of the
different ways that plant viruses can be
introduced
and and understand the importance of
sanitation and movement restrictions
for introduction and management of
disease
and describe some of the ways that plant
viruses are managed
there are very few treatments for
post-infection so plant virus
diseases really rely on a heavy amount
of prevention
or incompatible reactions in terms of
resistance
and finally i hope i have
outcomes of plant virus mixed infections
including
synergistic disease and
more neutral or even antagonistic
interactions
with that i would like to acknowledge
some of the different people in my lab
who've helped with this work and
collaborators on the right hand side
a lot of the mln work that i was
became part of um started with dr peg
redenbaugh
and i have a number of different
researchers on the side here george
mahuku chuck niblet andrew kagundu
godfrey asaya and wang guy and
and folks in my lab who've done a lot of
this work with me um
kristin willey jane todd cezo malashwa
nitika katri
saranga helping out with the
bioinformatics jovia
and dale masali
with that thank you